dude with gun okay nitpick rants and I
am going to rant a little bit harder
about something that I touched on when I
did my review with Liz on Avengers
infinity war so I just I feel good
needed to just go into this I'm not sure
any more deeply than I did in the review
but I need to rant it out a little bit
harder than I did there so when we get
towards our climax with the assault on
Wakanda
where we have fan OSes followers the at
that point surviving members of the
Black Order attempting to assault the
city with this army of kind of monster
bug dog things and we've got all of our
heroes plus you know the wakandan army
all lining up to face these things and
you haven't we've seen what the
wakandans have you know they have all
this high-tech stuff and the shields and
their force fields and you've got to
chala they're in his armor and you've
got other people there as well you have
you've got the Hulkbuster with Bruce
Banner at the helm of it
you've got Falcon who's got wings you've
got cap who is not only an enhanced
super soldier but he's got new shields
provided to him by a by Wakanda and
there's Bucky with a gun a gun that
shoots regular bullets that was one of
the only things in the movie that took
me out of it while I was watching it I
it was a moat like when he cocked the
thing I'm like wait what because they're
fighting things unlike anything they
problem they don't they don't really
know what it is that they're up against
they they bring in Bucky because they
need all the help they can get and they
give him a weapon that is by far the
most out-of-date piece of tak
on the battlefield with limited ammo
capacity that needs constant reloading
and and we know is completely outmatched
by stuff that they probably got just
laying around Wakanda
what and like look I get that maybe it's
his preferred gun they actually kind of
hinted that a little bit even when he
has his little kind of banter with rock
and rock and rock is like gonna have
your gun no can I have your arm so you
know they hint that he's really partial
to this gun okay
I I get the impression that Bucky is
enough of a pragmatist that he would
favor a gun better suited for the
situation than just the one that
happened to be his favorite but whiskey
scenario sure he loves to tinker with
stuff and and I I mean I know they focus
on her I can't imagine she's the only
tech person in the entire country of
Wakanda you're telling me nobody could
rig up his gun that he likes with higher
end ammo with with laser something
better than that but some kind of energy
weapon that isn't gonna run out of ammo
the way his bullets are gonna run out
really damn quick especially with not
many things coming at him he just it's
just done it's just a couple of bullets
he's surrounded by all this tech all
this amazing stuff and they could have
given him anything and he's just got a
gun that he used it in Winter Soldier
which was I don't even remember what
four years ago so even we just even with
a universe with the way technology's
been advancing rapidly in the MCU even
people not what kind of would have way
more advanced guns and everything than
that available to them does ain't
nothing about what they're gonna have
they in Wakanda you were being invaded
by aliens give him something more than
just a gun and that is really kind of
the one moment in that film that took me
out of it cuz it's this one little
detail that just kind of drives me nuts
so there we go Bucky and is
sentimental attachment to a to a gun
that you know if they had maybe if
they'd built up the fact that he was
particularly attached to this gun in the
earlier films I could have let it fly
you know how like Jane really loves
Veera in Firefly but they didn't so I
don't buy it and it bugs me so that's my
one nitpick on Infinity Ward did you
have a nitpick do you agree with mine do
you think I should shut up whatever your
thoughts are maybe don't tell me to shut
up or do but find a more polite way to
say whatever they are drop something
down the comments let's talk about it
there's all the stuff to do such as
support me on patreon like subscribe
follow me on Twitter podcast bet that
down links for all this stuff down in
the description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]